hey guys i'm ryan wright hey guys i'm
salamander sally we're gonna do a super
bowl
marathon of
movie trailers and we'll talk about it
afterwards but yeah i just sort of
composed them all into one video didn't
watch any of them just threw them all
into one imovie project let's check this
shiznit out let's do it see what
the four million it costs like four and
a half million dollars to put a 30
second hat out for a movie really yeah
so can i book one of those commercials
well they got the book the movie first i
don't know what order it's going to be
in we're doing minions hot tub time
machine 2 tomorrowland terminator 5
genesis avengers age of ultron kingsman
the secret service so we're looking at
six
30 second trailers are you guys ready
i don't even know if i'm ready yeah
and i don't think okay whatever let's
just
let's watch this touchdown
what if there was a
where nothing place
impossible
what
sweet
i wanted more
this world need something more powerful
than any of us
trouble always comes around
ultra
in the flesh
a
military
from the inside
i like that i like that a lot
something's coming up next
this big game weekend hot tub time
machine 2 reminds you if you're gonna
take on the patriots patriot blue he
looks like captain crunch has sex with
paul revere that's what it is make sure
their balls are fully inflated what's
happening
time machine tom cruise
okay let's take a quick
yes
oh my god
everything's changed
i've been waiting for you
i'll be back what
like a spy of sorts
it's a bit much
you and your buddies will jump up and
down for hours while screaming
indecipherable nonsense like
you will spill 64 ounces of a really
sticky fruity drink all over the guy in
front of you and you will likely remove
your cute little blue denim overalls and
why why do you do this
because you're a minion
swim those pants baby
i love them
that was actually kind of fun to just
watch that was fun it's just like a
quick little overview of that maybe you
want more
yeah i know that it got me excited for
movies that are coming out in 2015. yeah
you do it was like whoa good time for
movies 2015. yeah yeah i mean the first
one we saw was tomorrowland which showed
us nothing really that is one of my most
anticipated films of the year me too
because i totally i'm obsessed with
tomorrowland like the area in disney
disneyland i've been waiting for them to
make a movie about that park because
that part of the park because it's just
so cool i don't know the director brad
bird who did mission impossible for the
incredible incredibles ratatouille like
he's a fantastic director main reason i
want to see it and to put him in a live
action disney film
smart move smart move i'm that's the one
i'm most excited for yeah even though
that was the one that didn't show us
anything i know but i kind of like that
and age of ultron like they gave us
slightly new images but any new image
you get from age of ultron
it's like great epic yeah
it's like it could be a slight second
and you're like wow
yeah that film's gonna be [ __ ] epic
man because it's always like a little
bit extra of scenes we've already seen
but even that little moment you get
you're like yeah cause it's just like
the most anticipated like ever yeah out
of all of these i think is it's the most
out of the six we saw yeah definitely i
mean like i think star wars is the most
scientific oh god i've totally i don't
think they're getting a super bowl
commercial this year then hot tub time
machine two they made it a lot bigger
than the first one it's more crazy a lot
more time travel usually what they do
with sequels when the first one didn't
do too well they try and go like above
and beyond but it still doesn't look
that funny to me i've seen like four
trailers for it and i'm still like it
looks okay the only thing i laughed
about was a possible tom cruise and his
balls and then when it wasn't tom cruise
i was like okay now it's not funny no i
like the actor adam scott he's in parks
and rec and he i think he's a funny
actor he's been in uh have you seen step
brothers yes he was uh will ferrell and
john c riley's
douche bag brother oh yeah
okay but then it was followed up by
terminator genesis that looks so cool
yeah i've seen like that's like the
third trailer i've seen and they usually
show arnold sometimes but this one they
put him like front and center yeah they
were making him like like you know he's
the lead in this one
see the shot when he he was younger yeah
yeah no they they actually took the
actual footage of the first terminator
and they like cropped it out or
something and put him in there yeah
that's insane to see them like really
promoting arnold front and center
because at first they were like kind of
putting him to the side but i think they
finally realized like what people really
want us to see arnold back in
terminators maybe they tried to do the
whole like oh
it's gonna be a mystery till you watch
the movie yeah i guess no people just
want to see arnold just like how people
just wanted to see godzilla like give me
godzilla yeah i think it's because
arnold's movies ever since he stopped
being governor have not been a success
like yeah none of them have really been
that successful
so i think they were like afraid to put
in front and center but i think like
with terminator come back this is
terminator you know it's like you want
to see arnold so yeah like even arnold
with gray hair is better than no arnold
at all
i'll be back i was like yeah yeah i was
waiting for it i like that moment in the
terminator trailer when he's when he
walks out of the police car and they're
falling off the bridge and he doesn't
even run
she's like i'm just gonna casually walk
there and reach out my hand but i think
he's cl i'm spending a lot of time on
terminator but what i think is cool
about terminator with actually making
arnold even look older than what he
looks like in real life i think that was
smart because from my understanding this
is an aging terminator that he's playing
this time rather than having it go oh
it's arnold like and he looks older they
they were like let's make him look older
because it feels intentional now yeah
you know it doesn't feel weird making it
look like oh he's older but let's try to
make him a little yeah exactly that
comes across really weird yeah sometimes
and kingsman the secret service looks
like a total blast of mine i didn't i
didn't i don't know what this is but
after watching the trailer i really
really wanted is that the first footage
you've seen of it yeah oh dude no that
film is
definitely one of the most anticipated
based off of anything a graphic novel oh
okay okay i figured it's a guy who did
kick ass and x-men first class yeah i've
said plenty about that film and i it
looks so good it looks like just a total
entertaining time the last one was
minions which the despicable me
franchise is something where i'm never
excited for the films but when i'm
watching them i'm having a really good
time that's true well i loved the first
one the second one i didn't like too
much except for the minions like the
minions were the only part that i liked
about the second despicable me and then
the ending like killed me that was the
best part of the movie who's the one in
the credits the manias are great and i
just really hope that
they do evolve them in a sense where we
can watch a whole story exactly it's
kind of hard to make a movie based off
you know a little side character because
it either bombs or it's really good yeah
because they're very two-dimensional
characters like how do you make them
have a story and characters and still be
really funny yeah you know and like
watch an hour and a half of it yeah
exactly so i'm hoping they pulled that
off well me too because i love them
anyway guys thanks for uh letting me
know that all those [ __ ] trailers are
out yeah if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
and salamander sally has a channel
called salamander sally
it's about her being a lizard
no
it is a salamander is a lizard but
that's not the point of my channel it's
just a nickname
right
well
do you feel you have kind of a lizard
look about you
uh
no
but an actress is like a chameleon
jake william damon
he has three first names
the following is inspirational and dare
i say
touching message is brought to you by
someone that needs a shout out mostly
for attention at least he's honest yeah
all right here we go dear ryan and the
real rejects team i found your channel
back when i first looked up reactions to
the force awakens teaser and you were
among the first few results
there's what
there's a lot i watched it and needed
more so i spent the next few days
pouring over all your awesome videos
nice he probably masturbated just wanted
to let you know that as someone who
knows good youtubers when
they see them you mean when you see them
you guys have become one of my favorite
channels joining my list of top channels
including here we go
well let's go let's go watch mojo screen
junkies jeremy the johns
and others
others like me i thought there was gonna
be like a long list
you all are down to earth hilarious and
i'd marry you all if i could but several
things that have to fall into place in
order for that to work such as the law
such as myself becoming bisexual as i
like women exclusively sorry ryan you
can go [ __ ] yourself now jake williams
he didn't say oh well he doesn't want to
be with me
no he said he'd be willing to be with
like he'd be willing to be bisexual just
to be with you oh
then i wouldn't suck his dick
wow that's pretty mean i just wouldn't i
can't imagine a penis being him maybe
receipt no
i just can't see a penis in my mouth
can't imagine it keep going in your rise
to youtube stardom you are well on your
way to greatness that's so nice quoted
by gandalf maximilian voldemort the 11th
the above name is an alias everyone here
is what jake william
damon
looks like he's so adorable
yeah
look at him yeah so would you say
maybe maybe